and joining us here right now on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is our
friend uh from the nfl network nfl media
group moved the sticks on twitter and he
does the uh lot chargers games locally
here on the radio in los angeles none
other than daniel jeremiah how you doing
dj
i'm doing great rich i uh i always say
me and money always say it when we leave
the uh when we leave the booth um we we
get the good fortune of calling games
for the most interesting team in the
league because there is drama every each
and every time they take the field it
doesn't matter who they're playing um
it's going to come down to the very end
so i guess if they're the most
interesting team in the world their
their slogan is stay going for it my
friend
right
by the way has anybody talked i don't
know if anybody's talked about that at
all um does that generate any
conversation well i mean it is it is it
is
other than clock management and and
challenging a replay
um you know whether to go for it instead
of kicking a field goal and then looking
at the final score is the easiest second
guest of an uh of a football coach i
think easiest second guess that's out
there yeah i think there is a clear
divide right there is that old school
who i think have just they've been
accustomed to watching football a
certain way for you know 50 years
and they just i think they just kind of
struggle to wrap their minds around it
um so i last night and i said it during
during the broadcast i had absolutely no
problem uh with what staley did in that
game and how aggressive he was and um
you know calling this these games each
and every week i've seen this team i
think there's there's the analytics side
of it right which is
you know you're aggressive you're gonna
need points uh against the chief's
offense you know is is going to explode
at some point in time when you're
missing as many guys the charges were in
the secondary you're not going to keep a
lid on that for the entire game so
you're trying to build up a little bit
of a buffer so there's that side of it
if you don't get it you give them a long
field there's that side of it but to me
watching them every week rich like
there's there's teams that require a
certain kind of mindset to play their
best football and when they played the
minnesota vikings in that game they went
to conservative approach and they punted
at the you know like the 45 or the 50 on
a fourth down and they just they didn't
really play aggressive and all the talk
was yeah they're not pushing the ball
down the field what happened to the
chargers and and they got outside of
themselves and i think you never want to
lose a football game but you feel a lot
better walking out of the stadium losing
knowing you kind of did it the way you
play and your brand of football and your
style and i think that the players
embrace that as well no i know that's
nine points though knowing the chargers
though you can't guarantee that all nine
would have been put on the board right i
mean it's just but but but
the i i'll just walk you through it the
way i started the show first first one i
have no problem with i mean you're
coming out of the gate you get that huge
return you know you're not gonna set the
tone by putting a three on the board
against kansas city that just almost put
a 50 on the board right so i don't
the one right before the half
um
i think you know i understand you want
to go up two scores certainly when
kansas city gets the ball on the other
side of the break but going up one full
touchdown means they can only tie the
game on you to start and you get the
ball and it's a tie game but you get the
ball first kind of like
the way the game started you know and
then the third one
i would have gone up for i'm very honest
and and and i totally know
that the the the touch the touchdown
drive that they went 97 yards and came
up with nothing because they fumbled it
inside the five they did successfully go
forward on fourth down to set up that
drive inside the five uh though i would
have taken the points there there's just
no two ways about it i would have gone
and gotten those three there the first
one i don't have a problem with um so
i'll put that on the floor to you daniel
yeah the only one that i will that i
will um that i'd be okay with taking the
criticism on would be the one right
before the half
because there's no benefit of backing
them up you know it's like again the
half's over so if you don't get it it's
not like they're gonna they're they're
gonna get the ball inside the five you
figure you get to stop and get the ball
right back which i think factors into a
lot of these decisions is forcing this
kansas city chief's offense to have to
go the long way um so that one i can
understand
and saying that
keenan allen is wide open and if he gets
that ball up and over the top of
sorenson keenan allen could have caught
it like a punt so they had good play
calls on these fourth downs they had
guys open
um and you had some drops and you had
the you know sorenson made a nice play
there but keenan was wide open behind
him so
then richard i just kind of i
i think it's easy to look at these in a
vacuum but when again you're watching
this team all year long
fourth and ninth in the first meeting
against kansas city fourth and nine at
the 35-yard line which is a you know you
would think is a good time to attempt a
field goal to try and take the lead in a
tie ball game late in the fourth quarter
they went for it because they knew they
didn't want patrick mahomes with the
ball in his hands right you know chasing
three points it's too easy for him so
they went for it they got it they won
that game they go three of three on
fourth downs against cleveland and win a
shootout they play against cincinnati
just two weeks ago on their opening
drive same exact thing as we had last
night they have a fourth and goal at the
four they go for he throws a touchdown
to keenan allen and they jump on
cincinnati early in that game so
i mean look you can look back on them
and say
uh you know save points i just i don't
know how you play against kansas city
chiefs even knowing that this offense
isn't quite what it's been and and you i
have that image in my mind of the san
francisco 49ers bludgeoning and beating
the tar out of that team for three
quarters and then all of a sudden the
chiefs kick it in gear and those points
come and they come fast and they come in
bunches and i think without derwent
james asante samuel louie gilman yeah i
think he knew i think staley knew that
was a ticking time bomb before that was
getting ready to go off daniel jeremiah
here on the rich eisen show so did you
see a super bowl team in the chiefs last
night so what you saw i thought i
thought that that was what the offense
has looked like when it's been right and
you know outside of the raider games
they haven't looked like that for the
majority of the year right but when
mahomes the magic is when mahomes is
extending plays rich i mean every big
play was him escaping the pocket getting
away from pressure and i don't i mean
the charge had some backups back there
but no excuse nobody in the league is
covering kyrie kill for five seconds
nobody in the league is going to be able
to cover kelsey when you've got that
much time to work like that's when
that's where the magic happens and i i
would say
you know i've talked about the charges
missing guys obviously the chiefs are
without you know chris jones is the
second best
interior defensive lineman of football
uh and they're without their number one
corner and willie gays is starting
linebacker so both teams are missing
guys i i would just say in that game you
had the stars at the end of the game
with those big three on offense and then
i to me that it was one of the best
linebacker games
from anybody this year that nick bolton
played the rookie he was all over the
field some of those big fourth down
stops he was he was incredible man he
kept him in the game without nick bolton
in that game i think that that game
could get away from the chiefs but man
he was he was phenomenal in a year where
we've got
you know the micah parsons and you know
the the jamar chases and rashaan slaters
like this dude is playing lights out for
the kansas city chief i mean if i told
you right around what mid mid october
right when the chiefs were three and
four and the patriots were two and four
right or whatever they were um three and
four let's say both went three and four
it could have been the same time that
these are the two teams they're going to
be sitting atop the afc and one will be
the one standing in the way the other of
going to the super bowl what if i told
you that then because that seems to be
the case right now here after the
kickoff to week 15. daniel yeah i mean i
think i would have believed you on the
chiefs because i always said you know
look mahomes they're going to kind of
figure things out and spagnolo just has
this long track record of the defense
getting better as the year goes along so
i think i would have i would have bought
it the one i wouldn't have bought is is
that with mac jones
and you know kind of a new cast of
characters there in new england after
what we saw last year that they would be
sitting in the top perch i don't know
that i would have bought that one well
you know i was at that halloween game
that you were calling in so far and the
patriots the way that mack was running
the offense and looked so comfortable
and then the team playing so terrific
defensively against herbert and then the
offense uh taken time off towards the
end of the game sliding out of bounds
with seven minutes i mean sliding to
stay inbounds with like seven minutes to
go situationally brilliant i thought to
myself this looks like the belichick
patriots man that's what this looks like
and i'm like i came down to the show
that on november 1st and i'm like that's
a playoff team i saw
in sofi and
you know they haven't lost since then
daniel no they're incredible and they
they dominate on special teams um it's
not just you know the kicking and the
punting it's their the way they cover
kicks it's matthew slater and three or
four other you know outstanding special
teams players that they
they commit to even though they might
not have a role on either side of the
ball so they're they're as good as it
gets with their um defensively you know
they're going to be sound and i think
you've seen the additions that they've
made in free agency have been
outstanding um and then the offense is
just like you said they're not they
don't mind drives that and in a kick
that's their formula you know everybody
has a little different formula that's
their formula you know field goals and
punts the way their defense and special
teams play um that those are wins and
mac jones has been uh has been very
consistent at being able to protect the
football and and make great choices so
that's that's patriots football i mean
my only thing will be once we get into
the postseason i think that gets you i
think that brand of football gets you to
the postseason i think historically once
you get in the postseason rich your
quarterback's going to have to make what
tom had to make which are those four or
five you know big time throws to get you
through the tournament and that's that's
still tbd mac's been awesome uh but
that's still tbd if he's gonna be able
to to make those throws that tom has
made for you know 20 years daniel
jeremiah here on the rich eisen show uh
the rest of the season the cardinals uh
are are going to be without deandre
hopkins and they hope to get him back
for the playoffs that they should make
with a win against the detroit lions
this weekend you got the bucks and the
packers um playing lights out football
the rams just came up with their best
performance in a couple of months you
might have to say or at least over a
month how do you suss out the uh nfc
that you've got the 49ers playing
similar to their super bowl season of a
couple of years ago and the cowboys
having their quarterback in a slump
apparently what do you got for me on the
nfc front dj well first first of all
rich it is a uh
it is so nice to be able to make any
type of a prediction right now because
of the number of injuries and guys that
we've seen with all with the covet
pop-up like
you're covered so no matter what you say
you're going to be covered because
there's going to be so many key players
right that are out in these games like i
don't know how you really predict
anything successfully so
i i just know that you that you hit it
with the rams and the niners kind of
starting to play their best ball at the
right time i'm a little bit worried
about the cardinals um they've had a
fantastic year but that is a huge piece
of their offense
and these kind of gotta have it games
coming forward without deandre hopkins
so that would concern me a little bit i
think
the class of the nfc is is the two that
you mentioned with green bay
um and with tampa and to me you know
when i look at that potential matchup
which it looks like we're headed towards
eventually
i think that the the tampa offensive
line i think can take over a football
game that would be the difference to me
that's why i'd still put them up there
obviously tom and aaron i guess you
could say maybe cancel each other out
because they're so fantastic
but i do think that tampa and their
offensive line and maybe being able to
control the ball a little bit with their
run game could be the difference there a
few minutes left here with daniel
jeremiah on the rich eisen show
when you're talking to members and
friends in your talent evaluation
community scouting community front
office community and the name urban
meyer comes up what's uh what is
the discussion like
daniel
um well i mean i think you hear some of
the same
terms that you probably hear if you went
to the grocery store you know dumpster
fire train wreck nightmare
um all the above i mean it was a
catastrophic failure there and
you know i think that in talking to my
buddies and i felt the same way that the
second he didn't board that plane that
that was that was over and it was just a
matter of how bad it was gonna get from
that point on now the one thing i would
dispute
you know i saw some some people with the
take that he didn't you know he's jumped
the line and he did not deserve that job
but he should have never got that job
that's ridiculous this guy's one of the
winningest coaches in college football
history like there's nowhere else for
him to go that was you kind of graduate
to the nfl at that point in time if you
wanted opportunity i i think he he paid
his dues and he earned that shot now he
completely completely blew it as bad as
you can blow it but i don't buy the fact
that he wasn't qualified to be the head
coach of the jacksonville jaguars i just
think the guy came in there with a
tremendous amount of arrogance
came in there to show the nfl what he
knew instead of going to the nfl to
learn from those inside the nfl and i
think that's what got him
yeah
i think you nailed every last one of
them and my guys here on the set
they they still shake their heads when
they hear the whole concept about
getting on the plane that it was that it
was done
because they texted me the video that
weekend of what urban was doing in a bar
and my first thought was wait a minute
is that now because that means he didn't
get on the plane with the team
our minds were on something else
yes
and that's like there was no putting it
back together there was no putting it
back together after a month there wasn't
there couldn't have been right
right no no there that that was that was
the beginning of the end there and
um you know there were the questions
coming in there now i'll be honest with
you rich i thought that had a chance to
work just right the guy the guy won
everybody's ever been and this is you
know bowling green in utah it wasn't
just florida and ohio state um i thought
it had really had a chance to work i
when they put the staff together i did
not love the fit there it seemed kind of
awkward and then it was like every
everything you heard was like oh no this
is not good i mean throughout the whole
process do you remember early on when
they said hey are you going to try and
put in some of the clemson stuff to make
trevor lawrence comfortable no we're
going to teach trevor lawrence how to
play nfl quarterback i'm like oh okay so
don't do everything you can to make your
young quarterback comfortable that's
that's that's a great strategy um it was
just kind of like all the way all the
way through the process it was just one
mishap after another and um and then i
think some personal failings factored in
there as well and you lose the respect
you lose respect to your guys and you
can see it when you watch the games when
the players come off the field after a
big play you go to give them a hug and
it was like
um they want any part of it you know you
could see it it was it was very evident
well maybe it could have been better if
uh when he asked his coaches to defend
their resumes somebody could have said
well i'm a three-time cif
champion football quarterback a harbor
league champion in basketball in the
1999 southern conference champion which
is what you handed to me on a
on a card on game day morning i didn't i
didn't want you know i didn't want the
producers coming to rich and being like
hey rich you know dj this segment we're
doing every week do we stay with it and
he goes it's your resume i need to know
if he's a winner uh do we keep him on
these segments on game day morning i
don't know he's got to prove himself
here because i'm looking at it from the
outside i know i'm a winner i want to
make sure this kid's not a loser that is
a very impressive resume daniel very
impressive
worthy of you by the way
i was going to tell you real quick to
change the subject okay
i just need to confess something because
i felt so me and money felt so guilty
last night okay um we leave the game so
far as you know right next to nfl
network
we go back to the uh green room to kind
of let the traffic die down well make
sense
i don't know if you're aware of this but
they feed the thursday night crew i mean
like kings in there so we come back
there when nobody's everybody's left the
building there are a zillion pizza boxes
and cookies and we're like raccoons
all the food
that they have left out there on the
table and it was like
and then and then kathy in the makeup
room she somehow was still there she
comes in there and sees this whole thing
and she's just what
a why are you guys here and what are you
doing with kathy you didn't see anything
well
well here's the deal uh you're welcome
because that feast is built on the backs
of all the cheese cubes and um grit
crackers and and
i guess
concession stand
nuggets that we we ate for all those
years on the road on thursday night so
you're welcome daniel that's built on
the back of of all those uh culinary
treats that we were fed uh and yeah in
the trailer i i appreciate it you're
welcome your heart condition for my
satisfaction the good trait
before i let you go sir uh dj uh tj
jefferson and chris brockman have a
little wager going on right here
uh and i'd ask you right now uh as we
are talking here uh uh mid-december of
2021 who would you rather be on with in
this bet
and the wager is can he pick a top five
pick chris brockman says yes
tj jefferson says no who would you be
with right now if you could daniel
jeremiah well
you're saying me saying no means i don't
think kenny's good that's not fine i'm
just saying dj
i get to feel this one excuse me mr pitt
panther that doesn't need to be any
softer this is the bet
top five yes he says brockman yes
daniel all right i like i like kenny
pickett okay i do oh but i i don't think
the detroit lions are going to take him
over those two defensive linemen
i don't see the houston texans taking
him over those guys jacksonville has the
third pick and they've got trevor
lawrence the jets are not going to give
up on zach wilson after a year that
means it would come down to as we stand
right now the new york football giant
yeah taking kenny pickett with the fifth
pick that is that it's early for me but
it's conceivable so i think this bet is
gonna ride all the way through the draft
process if i was going to gamble right
now i'll say it'll be a new gm who gives
danny dimes one more crack at it he
doesn't go in the top five but it's
gonna that's a great bet or the jaguars
trade out all but what you're saying i'm
looking forward what you're saying is
the first hour while we're on the set in
vegas
next april is going to be a sweat for
these two guys where they're watching at
home is what you're saying it's going to
be a sweat absolutely at home at home
i'll be by the pool
[Laughter]
i want the steelers to draft pickets so
that's what i'm hoping okay no that's
very good we're not saying he's he's bad
i mean you know i mean tom brady was
199. that's a good point all right
daniel thanks for the time good bet okay
there you go there you go all right dj
you be well thanks for the time we'll
chat soon thanks rich there you go
that's the channel that's the champion
that's the winner daniel jeremiah move
the sticks hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here